tomorrow voters across the country are
heading to the polls and perhaps the
most watch Li closely watched race and
the battle is in Virginia for governor
Republican Ed Gillespie is trying to
score a major upset over Democrat Ralph
Northam and he joins us now from
Alexandria now that I got the marbles
out of my mouth and gillespie great to
see you this is a this is a contest that
has kind of gone both directions it's
tightened up in recent days you're ahead
and a bunch of polls narrowly ahead tell
us what you're going to do to make the
lives of the average Virginians better
when you're governor well first of all
I'm gonna increase job creation by 25%
and I have a plan to cut our individual
income tax rates by 10% across the board
Laura that has not been done since those
tax rates were set in 1972 45 years ago
and we need those jobs we need that
opportunity we're stuck here in Virginia
our economic growth rate right now is
0.6 percent and we're 39th out of 50
states in economic growth Virginia and I
truly believe that when it comes to
economic growth and job creation
Virginia should be first in the country
and we can be with the right policies
but we don't have those policies now and
the only way we get them is by winning
this election tomorrow and I'm confident
we're going to I can feel the momentum
everywhere we're going and I've been
everywhere over the course of the past
well certainly the past year but just in
the past week and I can tell you the
crowds have been great and the
enthusiasm and energy and intensity is
all on our side right now and and when
you look at the landscape right now just
the among the electorate there's a lot
of anger out there a lot of
a lot of fight and the people for a lot
of reasons how does the governor deal
with that I mean you you have the
establishment GOP you have the populace
you have the the left and they have
their own problems how do you deal with
it
the anger well Laura I deal with it by
putting forward policies that I know
will be good for all Virginians and I've
got 21 specific detailed policy
proposals on my website Ed for Virginia
comm that I know will increase job
creation here I know improve our schools
I know that they'll ease traffic
congestion so that we can get home in
time for dinner with our families I know
that they will make our communities
safer address the awful opioid and
heroin epidemic we're dealing with here
in the Commonwealth of Virginia and I
find that as I talk to my fellow
Virginians and I talk about policies and
the concerns they have and my solutions
to them you could talk to everybody
about that and I take my campaign to
every corner of the Commonwealth and to
every voter in Virginia and I'm well
received everywhere because they want to
know what do you for how you gonna make
our life better and Edie I really
appreciate your joining us on the eve of
the campaign you didn't campaign with
Donald Trump
but Republicans I think are you not
uniting and unifying and we really look
forward to reporting this race tomorrow
so thanks so much and up next